hello everyone and welcome today's
webinar an introduction to
characterization of biomolecules using
analytical ultracentrifugation i'm ross
where he will of Beckman Coulter life
sciences and I'll be moderating today's
live event I'd like to thank labyrinth
for presenting today's webinar which is
brought to you by Beckman Coulter life
sciences a global leader in
centrifugation and life science
instrumentation before we begin I'd like
to remind everyone that this event is
interactive I encourage you to
participate by answering a few poll
questions during the presentation and by
submitting questions for a speaker at
any time to do so simply type in the ask
a question box and click send we'll
answer as many questions as we have time
for at the end of the presentation if
you have trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation click on the support tab
found on the top right of the
presentation window or report your
problem by clicking on the ask a
question box located on the far left of
your screen this presentation is
educational and thus offers continuing
education credits please click on the
continuing education credits tab located
at the top right of the presentation
window and follow the process to obtain
your credits with great pleasure I now
present today's speaker my friend and
colleague Akash Bhattacharya of Beckman
Coulter life sciences Akash has
extensive experience in various
biophysical characterization methods
including analytical ultracentrifugation
Akash is currently a senior application
scientist Beckman with a focus on
expanding and developing analytical
ultracentrifugation applications for
Akash is complete bio please visit the
biography tab at the top of your screen
Akash please go ahead and begin your
presentation Thank You Russ good morning
everyone thank you for attending this
which is the first of a three-part
webinar brought to you by Beckman
Coulter the topic of this webinar is an
introduction to the characterization of
biomolecules using analytical
ultracentrifugation or AUC now this
technique and you see it's something
that's been around for pretty much 90
years at this point and it's played a
fundamental role in biology chemistry
and material science the very first
research in a UC was done by Swedberg
who received the Nobel Prize in
Chemistry in 1926 and that was done also
in the same time as John Parra who
received the Nobel Prize in Physics also
in 1926 for his study of sedimentation
equilibrium and AUC has been an
extremely powerful tool in biology and
chemistry through all of these many
years and has played a role in
experiments including for example the
meselson stall experiment which deals
with DNA replication and has been
frequently described as possibly the
most elegant experiment in all of
biology ever conducted so we are really
excited to bring you this webinar
particularly the context of the new
Optima a UC instrument which was
introduced just two years ago by Beckman
Coulter this new instrument are shows in
a new era of capability and extends its
potential into previously unexplored
sample areas so with that being said
let's get started this is a roadmap of
our talk today I'm going to spend the
first part of the talk giving you an
introduction to the technique then we
will talk about the actual operation of
the AUC instrument and the final part of
the talk will delve into some
application areas so the introduction to
the technique of AUC so when you're
talking about biophysical techniques
there is always a trade-off between the
different things that you want out of
your technique of choice and what you
get from your technique of choice so
you'd ideally want a technique which
gives you substantial resolution and
detail in the measurement process at the
same time you want a technique which is
relatively easy to use and hopefully not
very expensive and finally you want a
technique which also provides you
flexibility and versatility and I'm very
happy to say that analytical
ultracentrifugation is a technique which
kind of sets in the sweet spot and
offers you all of these different
characteristics
so let's find out a little bit more
about the signal in a very small
nutshell what does AUC do it separates
analytes based upon size now at this
point I want to mention that through the
rest of this webinar I'll be using the
word analyte and the word sample in a
more of this interchangeable fashion
they mean the same thing in a little bit
more detail you see it's really just a
versatile technique to quantitatively
characterize biological systems and
other systems as well and this is the
most important part in the solution
phase so what does AUC give you it
provides you with whole molecule or
whole analyte thermodynamic parameters
including but not limited to size shape
the molecular mass of your system the
aggregation state of your system if your
system is forming a complex and it also
gives you information about the
stoichiometry of the complex and finally
if your system binds to any other
biomolecules in solution then analytical
ultracentrifugation can also
quantitatively define that binding by
giving you a binding constant and all of
the calculations of analytical
ultracentrifugation are based upon ab
initio hydrodynamic theory as a matter
of fact the fundamental physics of the
process of analytical
ultracentrifugation as it occurs on the
experimental setup we use was described
by all a Lam way back in 1929
however the computational ability to
solve the equation which he had
described only became available in the
1990s which led to a renaissance reached
up what we'll call the new generation
today okay so with that being said I
would like to hand over control to my
colleague Ross for a moment so that he
can push out the first poll question
Ross
all right thank you gosh our first poll
question is to better understand our
audience today
what is your familiarity with a UC and
we'll give you about 15 seconds to go
ahead respond and then etosha will pick
up
you
okay let's move on to the next slide so
I want to draw a line for you from
ultracentrifugation that is to say prep
ultracentrifugation because this is a
technique which is going to be familiar
to many members of our audience
especially those who are involved in
cell biology or in viral adji and the
line is to be drawn from prep you see
two analytical ultracentrifugation so if
you consider that half of the effort of
a biochemistry project of any kind is to
purify products which are made by living
cells then what you're really trying to
do is to separate the product of
interest from the rest of the components
of the cell so this is a process which
is done by ultra simplification so what
then is analytical ultracentrifugation
very simply put it is the method which
characterizes the thing that you're
trying to purify and yes the fundamental
physics of analytical
ultracentrifugation depends very much on
the physics of ultra centrifugation
so to give you a more concrete example
of what I'm talking about let us
consider two different molecules of DNA
or to be more specific they are really
the same molecule of DNA as in the
sequence is the same however one of
those molecules of DNA is super coiled
and extremely compact and the other
molecule of DNA has been treated with a
restriction enzyme
therefore it is next or it is linearized
and it is obviously no longer as compact
as the other super coiled version of the
same molecule so if you use an ultra
centrifugation experiment then at the
end of the experiment your sample tube
will have these clearly separated bands
where one of the Bands corresponds to
the linearized or nicked DNA the other
band corresponds to the super coiled DNA
now it's important to note why this
happens this separation occurs because
one component or one analyte in this
experiment clearly sediments to the
bottom of the sample tube faster than
the other component
this is something which occurs instead
of a preparation ultracentrifuge there
is a Beckman Coulter product known as
the Optima EX p.m. widely used in cell
biology and in viral on T by which you
measure how quickly one analyte
sediments to the bottom of the cell is
known as the sedimentation coefficient
and it is defined by something called
the Swedberg equation which I am now
going to put up over here but I'm going
to talk about in more detail very
shortly so again drawing this line from
prepara t'v to analytical
ultracentrifugation well what prep you
see does is that it separates analytes
which sediment differently in the same
tube in the same buffer in the same
experiment this is because of a simple
fundamental principle of physics which
states that objects which have densities
which are different from that of the
buffer medium will either sediment to
the bottom of the sample tube or will
float to the top of the sample tube over
the course of a ultra centrifugation
experiment and what AUC does is that it
monitors this movement of the analyte
and processes that information to obtain
the thermodynamic parameters that you as
a biophysicist order biochemists are
interested in obtaining and the
instrument which does all of this is the
optimal analytical ultracentrifuge
brought to you by Beckman Coulter
okay so why would you choose a UC over
the many other biophysical techniques
which are commonly available there are
several really good reasons to do so the
first one is that a UC will characterize
your biomolecules in the native state
there is no requirement for a substrate
a matrix or a reporter molecule of any
kind and all of these different things
add complications to your system of
interest which you would have to
otherwise account for in a UC
experiments you don't have to deal with
these problems the second advantage is
that a UC experiments are
non-destructive once the experiment is
completed you can always collect the
sample and repurpose it for something
else
and finally
information a you see is a technique
which gives you thermodynamic
information greater than that which you
can obtain we are using a whole host of
other techniques including various light
scattering chromatography and
spectroscopy spectroscopy related
techniques so really what you should put
should perhaps be pinking off is these
different instruments which I have put
on the screen over here such as DLS SBR
and what have you all of these
instruments provide information which is
really preliminary information which you
can then use to design an imaginative
auc experiment which will give you the
thermodynamic parameters that you seek
in the detail that you want however does
it mean that AUC is an infallible
technique and does it have no
limitations that is not the case a UC
does have certain limitations and those
are the following
what a UC provides to you is bulk
thermodynamic parameters bulk is
important here what it cannot provide to
you is the atomic level resolution which
you would seek via either NMR
spectroscopy or x-ray crystallography
and again the second part of the first
sentence thermodynamic parameters a UC
provides you with equilibrium
thermodynamic parameters but it's not
very good at providing you with a direct
monitoring of reaction kinetics that is
of course something for which you would
use a technique like stop flow however
being cognizant of these limitations it
is definitely possible to design
imaginative AUC experiments which shed
light upon your experiment which on your
system of interest which no other
technique can provide
okay so with that being said let's move
over to the forces in AUC and what they
can tell you so this is important in the
context of what happens to your sample
in an AC experiment so the AC experiment
is conducted inside what we call a
sector shaped cell or a sector cell this
is called the sector cell because if you
take a horizontal cross-section of such
a cell then it literally looks like the
sector of a circle as a shown diagram
over here this sector of a circle spins
around the axis demarcated by a at a
very high speed and the part of the
sector which is closest to this axis of
rotation is the first part is what
contains the air gap and there is
nothing in there apart from air but deep
part of the sector cell which is
radially outward from the air gap
contains both buffer as well as analyte
and the analyte shown here in the cyan
circle moves radially outward from
position X all the way to position Y
which is at the very bottom of this
sector cell and when it's it's moving
radially outward shown by the direction
of sedimentation arrow in red then the
different forces which act upon it are
shown as follows the centrifugal weight
of this object it measures the mass of
the analyte the buoyant force on the
object measures the volume of the
analyte and finally the frictional force
on the object measures the shape of the
object so these three different forces
it's important to know how they the
mathematics of their interaction because
analyzing that essentially gives us the
thermodynamic parameters which we seek
so to summarize what I've been telling
you so far what analytical
ultracentrifugation does is that it
takes a sample tube and spins it around
the rotation axis really really fast and
in doing so everything inside the sample
tube is subjected to a very large
centrifugal acceleration which is
radially outward and as we do so the
analytical Elka centrifuge brings to
bear an arrangement of detector optics
which observes what happens to a given
analyte or sample over the course of the
experiment in other words how its
sediments to the bottom of the sample
tube this process of how its sediments
is really the information content of NAC
experiment and that is what we end up
and lysing mathematically so with that
being said we are done with the
introductory part of this talk and it's
time to move over to the operational
aspect of analytical a personification
so let's get started this is a very
quick tour of the AUC Hardware the
Optima AUC comes with a couple of
different types of rotors you can get
either a four-hole rotor or 1/8 hole
rotor the 4 volt rotor will spin up to
60,000 rpm the 8th hole rotor will go up
to 50,000 rpm so depending on whether
your system of interest requires high
throughput or whether it requires higher
speeds
you make the choice of rotor depending
on that the loading of sample into the
cell is very simple it is shown here in
this picture well I where you can see
that sample is being loaded via a narrow
stem pipette tip and what you can also
see is the actual sector shape of the
cell where the sample is being loaded
once you've loaded up sample getting the
detector modules aligned into position
is as simple as turning a couple of
knobs and then you're good to go with
starting your experimental
all right so now that we've got the
experiment going let's take a look at
what the detection apparatus looks like
so there are two different types of
optical arrangements available to you
interference optics and absorption
multi-wavelength optics we will be
discussing these in more detail and
subsequent webinars but for the purposes
of today's introductory webinar what
matters is that will keep the optics
systems in the same way there's a light
source which sends a beam of light we
are a few mirrors through a cell which
is inside a rotor and the rotor itself
is of course spinning and then the light
comes out from the bottom of the cell
and impinges upon a detector system so
the data that is acquired is sample
concentration on the y-axis versus
radial distance from the axis of
rotation this radial distance is the
x-axis parameter and this data is
recorded repeatedly over the time course
of the experiment and that is what you
end up analyzing mathematically so let's
look at how we make the transition from
sample to data
going on in the slide let's unpack this
slowly on the top right you have a view
of what a sector cell looks like a given
cell housing contains two sectors the
left side sector is usually where you
put your buffer and the right side
sector is where you put your sample and
you'll notice that moving radially
outwards from the axis of rotation there
are three distinct regions inside the
sample sector the first region shown in
red shading is the air gap and it's
fairly obvious that all that's present
in that region is just air the second
region shown in cyan shading is is where
you've got buffer but you've got no
sample so if you look at both the first
region the air gap as well as the second
region where there's buffer but no
sample and then you compare it with the
figure down below you'll notice that
both of these regions correspond to
essentially zero absorbance in other
words there's really nothing which would
give you a signal but the last region
moving radially outwards shown in dark
blue is where you've actually got sample
and that sample plus buffer is where the
signal plateaus out at approximately 0.5
absorbance units now the zero
interesting thing is the transition from
the cyan region where you've got buffer
but no sample to the blue region where
you've got buffer and sample this
transition involves what we call the
meniscus and over the time course of the
experiment as the sediment as the
analyte sediments towards the bottom of
the sample tube this meniscus or this
boundary moves further and further to
the right and it is in fact the movement
of this boundary which is so information
rich in terms of actual experimental
data and that is really what we try to
analyze to obtain our thermodynamic
parameters
so if you look at what happens to a plot
of sample concentration or really
absorbance versus radial distance from
the beginning to the end of an
experiment it starts out as a complete
plateau and then a meniscus is formed as
we start the system spinning and as the
system spins and spins and the sample
sediments the meniscus moves further and
further to the right as all of the
sample is pelleting towards the bottom
of the tube
okay so I had briefly spoken about the
Swedberg equation earlier but now let's
look at the Swedberg equation in all of
its complete mathematical glory and here
it is the sedimentation coefficient s of
an analyte which measures how fast its
sediments it has a very specific
definition it is defined as the velocity
of the analyte per unit centrifugal
acceleration however there are a couple
of intuitive insights which I want you
to take away from this equation and they
are the following in any AUC experiment
a heavier object will sediment faster
than a lighter one
the first inside the second one in any
AUC experiment a denser object will
sediment faster than a less dense object
as a case example think of tiny Iron Man
Oh spheres versus polystyrene nanos
nanospheres the item nano spheres will
sediment faster and again in any a UC
experiment an isotropic object will
sediment faster than an anisotropic
object or a spread out object to give
you an example which we've already
looked at a super coiled DNA molecule
with sediment faster than a linearized
DNA molecule
okay so now that we have an intuitive
understanding of what the parameter
called sedimentation coefficient means
to us let us look at the different types
of experiments which people like to use
in an AUC workflow so the different
types of experiments are daily
sedimentation equilibrium and
sedimentation velocity and your choice
of which experiment you want to use
essentially depends on what you seek in
terms of information contents on that
experiment if you want the most accurate
possible calculation of molecular weight
and binding constant in an experiment
then you'll probably want to go for
sedimentation equilibrium which is a
long experiment run a relatively low
speeds and uses this 6 sector center
piece shown at the bottom of the column
however sedimentation equilibrium does
not give you an estimation of the shape
of the molecule of interest if you also
want to determine the shape of the
molecule of interest then you would opt
first element ation velocity and that is
an experiment which is done at
significantly higher speeds but for a
shorter duration of time just a few
hours and typically uses this to sector
center pieces as shown at the bottom of
the right side column
okay so now that we are done with the
operational aspect of analytical
ultracentrifugation it is time to start
talking about the applications of this
amazing technique so AUC is a technique
which plays a very important role in
both the discovery and research phase of
pharmaceutical work as well as the
quality control phase of pharmaceutical
work so let's first talk about the
strengths that AUC can bring to the
discovery part of Pharma and let's talk
about a few typical systems which you
might encounter so if you're looking at
proteins and nucleic acids or any
combination thereof
and the question that you're asking is
related to high resolution structure
then the technique of choice is going to
be extra crystallography in the mass
spectroscopy or sometimes cryo-electron
microscopy
however if your question is related to
dynamics a law study movement or really
what I like to call the shape-shifting
of biomolecules then yes you could use
NMR spectroscopy or small-angle x-ray
scattering but you run into a problem of
cost NMR spectroscopy requires isotope
labeled samples small angle x-ray
scattering is usually conducted at
synchrotron beamlines when you have to
travel halfway across the continents to
get to one analytical
ultracentrifugation a you see on the
other hand does not require such
expensive isotope labeled samples and is
a technique which you can have in-house
in the lab literally down the corridor
so it's both simple as well as
inexpensive now if you want to determine
the mass of a biomolecular system then
the most accurate technique that you can
probably seek is mass spectrometry
however mass spectrometry suffers from a
severe problem of dynamic range it is
very limited in the maximum size of the
systems that it can look at analytical
ultracentrifugation on the other hand
can look at systems which range in size
from say a dinucleotide all the way up
to intact viruses the dynamic range of a
UC is enormous and finally if you are
trying to answer questions related to
interactions if you're trying to find
binding constants and stoichiometry of a
given reaction then yes you do have
access to a whole range of techniques
including surface plasmon resonance
light scattering calorimetry
fluorescence and so on and so forth but
every one of these techniques is
ultimately limited in either its dynamic
range or in its requirement for some
kind of a label or reporter molecule or
in its requirements for some kind of a
matrix or substrate AUC
is a technique which does not require a
label it does not require a report or
molecule it has enormous dynamic range
and it analyzes the system in its native
state not requiring any kind of
substrate or matrix these are some of
the strengths which a UC brings to the
discovery part of Pharma research and
which is why it has been such a popular
technique over the years
now let's look at what a UC brings to
quality control
system of interest is a viral capsid or
a liposome and exosome any kind of drug
carrier vehicle then the typical
question that quality-control asks is is
this drug carrier vehicle actually
loaded with the cargo of interest or is
it empty and in this context people have
sometimes used techniques such as
transmission electron microscopy
however TEM suffers from the dual
problem of being firstly very expensive
and having a fairly non-trivial sample
preparation problem you see on the other
hand is far cheaper is a technique which
you can have in-house you can literally
run down the corridor and run
experiments on the AUC instrument next
door and it provides you with a single
point quality control metric which tells
you whether your prep is empty or
whether it is fully loaded with the
therapeutic cargo of interest it can
also tell you whether there is free
cargo floating around in your
formulation buffer which is also really
important in the QC context
if your work is on biologics or
biosimilars or antibodies then the
statement which is frequently made about
biologics is that the product is the
process so ideally you want to end up
with a product which is as pure as
possible and you want to know in a given
batch what is the fraction of the pure
protein versus aggregated protein and a
technique which is commonly used is size
exclusion chromatography
however AUC provides you with a better
dynamic range a better ability to
identify contaminants and yes
measurement in the native state AUC does
not require any kind of a matrix with
size exclusion chromatography columns
absolutely do and finally if you're
looking at labeled antibodies and you
want to determine the labeling
efficiency of your preparation process
then AUC can quantify the labeling
efficiency and again identify whether
you've got three label in the
formulation buffer so these are just
some of the strengths that AUC brings to
both the discovery part of
pharmaceutical work as well as the
quality control part of pharmaceutical
work and let's take a quick break while
Ross gets the next poll question out to
you trust
all right thanks Akash so our second
question is regarding your needs when
considering various characterization
techniques and so we'd like to ask in
your most important characterization
step what is most critical to your
process again we'll give you about 15
seconds and then a comfortable continue
on with the rest of the presentation
you
you
okay let's move on to
the next part of the talk so we've
discussed the utility of a you see in
both Discovery as well as in quality
control so let's look at some actual
case examples so a UC finds a role in
looking at biologics biosimilars
antibodies vesicles and gene therapy
so here's the first one let's look at
what AUC does in the biologics context
and I'm going to bring to you the
standard quality control question which
is what percentage of my sample prep is
a functional monomer and what percentage
is aggregated of course this question
will be modified on depending on whether
the functional state of your biologic is
a monomer or a timer but this is the
essential import of the question what
part of my sample is functional and what
part has aggregated so AUC can provide
information to answer this question down
to single digit percentage accuracy and
if there has been some unexpected
behavior during the drug purification
process which causes the appearance of
an unwanted multimers state then AUC can
quantify this behavior which will allow
you to go back and troubleshoot the
biochem steps involved in the
preparation and the example I want to
show you comes from my favorite biologic
which is insulin and this is an example
which we will be dealing as a detailed
case study in a subsequent webinar where
we will go through the workflow steps
but right now what I want to show to you
is the end result of the workflow steps
so what you end up with once you've done
the experiment process the entire data
mathematically is a plot of signal
concentration versus molecular weight
and if you look at this in detail you
will see that this example gives you
ninety three point eight percent of the
sample is present as a dimer and about
five point eight percent of the sample
is present as a hexamer and the rest of
this is basically trace oligomers so
this really is the kind of information
content which you can get out of a UC
for every single batch of your biologic
prep
however a UC brings certain strengths to
the table which other techniques used in
this context especially size exclusion
chromatography do not and a good example
of this is comes from this study which
was published inside reports about three
years ago so the researchers were
working on a few different antibody
samples and they were trying to
characterize these antibodies using size
exclusion chromatography and that
technique worked for the antibody called
Medi 578 which is shown in the trace in
red on the left side panel and comes up
as a very sharp peak in the ACC
experiment however when they tried to
characterize the second antibody which
was maybe nine one two which is shown in
the blue colored place on the left side
panel dish they ended up with this
hideous broad and asymmetrical peak and
of course this happens because certain
antibodies will interact with the
material that the ACC column is made out
of or it's matrix and if it does so then
it cannot be characterized by ACC at all
however AUC does not suffer from this
problem you will remember that AUC
analyzes samples in the native state and
when the researchers took this antibody
maybe nine one two and subjected it to
an AUC experiment they were able to find
that it has a small percentage of
monomer a much larger percentage of time
and then a small stress amounts of
higher-order structures and aggregates
and this kind of resolution is only
available because AUC treats this sample
and looks at it in its native state and
does not require any kind of an
interaction with the matrix which SEC
does and therefore AUC clearly gives you
information that size-exclusion
chromatography fails to do so
okay so the next type of example we'll
be looking at comes from the world of
vesicles so on vesicle what is a vesicle
it's really nothing but a drug carrier
vehicle a suitcase if you will accept
that the suitcase is made up of lipid
bilayers and the contents of that
suitcase are really what we are
interested in the contents of that
suitcase
are going to be the therapeutic cargo
that we want to load in it specifically
the drug of interest so the question
that is therefore going to be asked is
what percentage of my vesicle prep is
intact and how many what percentage of
my vesicle prep has broken down and then
can i distinguish between an intact but
empty vesicle versus a intact and drug
loaded vesicle and AUC can absolutely
answer both questions so let's look at
an example of that so this is an
experiment which we conducted and let's
work you through what's on screen the
blue trace on the left is data recorded
at 230 nanometers which is where we can
observe vesicles and this shows you
empty control liposomes and base
sediment at a value of s equals 100 now
if we take the same vesicles and by same
I mean the exact same size however these
are loaded with a therapeutic cargo a
drug then you get the Z trace also
recorded at the same absorption
wavelength of 230 nanometers but now you
will notice that the red trace with the
drug loaded liposomes has shifted to the
right and it's sediments at the much
larger value of s equals 250 this is of
course because the drug loaded liposome
has a much higher density than the empty
or controlled liposomes although it has
the same radius and remember what I had
mentioned about an intuitive
understanding of the Swedberg equation
denser objects sediment faster this is a
denser object has a higher s value and
with
sediment faster but really the most
interesting part of this experiment
comes from the green trace this green
trace was recorded from Delta obtained
at absorption at 490 nanometers 490
nanometers is an interesting wavelength
this is the wavelength at which the drug
molecule itself absorbs and I was able
to do this in the same experiment
because the brand new optima AUC and
span instrument manufactured by Beckman
Coulter has multi-wavelength capability
so I can actually look at different
wavelengths over the course of the same
experiment and I was monitoring what
happens to the drug itself turns out
that the drug sediments at the same s
value as that of the loaded liposome
which is very interesting because what
it tells us is that it it's it's
basically all encapsulated inside of the
loaded liposome and there is almost no
free drugs floating around in the
formulation buffer so this is a great
example of what AUC can bring to the
table for looking at drug loaded
vesicles it can offer you baseline
separation of an empty vesicle versus a
drug loaded vesicle and it can also
assess whether there is any free drug
floating around in the formulation
buffer or not in this case I was very
impressed with the quality control of
the product that I was looking at okay
so now that we've looked at vesicles
let's spend a moment to talk about gene
therapy so gene therapy what is gene
therapy the basic idea behind this is
that we are trying to introduce some
kind of a therapeutic gene into the host
DNA which will thereafter make proteins
and cure some kind of biological
condition so what you really need the
essential part of the preceding sentence
is introduce a host or introduce a
therapeutic gene and for that what you
need is a delivery vehicle and the
delivery vehicle of choice
for a lot of gene therapy project is
adeno-associated virus so what is
adeno-associated virus
it's basically a viral capsid which
comes with a large intrinsic genome and
that intrinsic genome can be modified to
carry a therapeutic cargo at which point
it's basically a transgenic cargo so the
question that we are really trying to
ask is the following what percentage of
my viral capsids in this prep that I'm
looking at are intact and how many of
them have broken down the second
question is can i distinguish between an
intact but empty viral capsid which only
has the outer protein coat but does not
have the transgenic cargo inside and an
ambach and a viral capsid which actually
contains the transgenic cargo and
finally can I say anything about
partially loaded viral capsids so AC can
absolutely answer questions one and two
and we are working on developing
methodologies to address question number
three which is partially loaded viral
capsids and it's worthwhile also noting
that this is very important in the
modern farmer context especially in the
light of recent guidelines which have
come to us from the FDA where they say
that viral particles that do not contain
the therapeutic gene are unlikely to
have therapeutic activity
however these particles themselves might
produce adverse reactions such as an
allergic response to end the light of
these guidelines is very important to
assess the quality or the purity of a
given viral prep and if you do an AUC
experiment on such a viral prep then you
will end up with a population
distribution of sedimentation
coefficients which look like this so
let's look at what's going on over here
empty capsules which are shown on the
left side of this trace within the
vertical black bars sediment at about 60
to 65 s and they're almost baseline
separated from partially loaded and
fully loaded capsules which are shown on
the right as it turns out partially
loaded capsules will sediment at around
90 to 95 s and fully loaded capsules
will sediment at around 105 to 110 s so
what you need to quantify whether your
viral prep has been successful or not is
ideally a single point a single number
QC metrics and the way to obtain that is
to simply integrate the signal between
the two vertical bars as shown and to
divide that by the total signal in your
experiment the number you end up getting
will be the percentage empty the lower
this number obviously the better the
quality of your prep so Optima AUC data
can therefore provide a single point QC
metric which will tell you the quality
of a given viral prep that you've made
and we are working on developing
methodologies to better quantify the
region I have marked out in the red
circle which is to say partial loads and
this brings us to the end of the
applications that I wanted to cover
and please remember that we will be
reaching out to you after this webinar
and ask you about the other application
systems that you would like us to cover
in subsequent webinars and you will have
an opportunity to provide feedback on
that but this also is the end of today's
talk so I wanted to thank all of you for
your attention and we will be pushing a
poll question out momentarily but before
we do so let's take a moment to also
look at forthcoming AUC events so we
will have two more webinars in this
calendar year in which we will be
talking about the theoretical
underpinnings of AUC will be going into
experimental setup in much more detail
and yes we will be talking about case
examples ranging from protein
aggregation to binding equilibria to
viral capsids again as well as other
kind of vesicles not just liposomes and
here we will solicit feedback from you
and if there is a system which you are
particularly interested in and you
believes that others would also want to
learn about then we might talk about
that as well will also give you an
overview of the different analysis
packages which are out there and finally
we will spend some time talking about
advanced analysis looking at noise and
sources of error how to account for them
and how they affect your experimental
results
annual auc conference this year is going
to be held in Christchurch New Zealand
in about two months time registration is
open at this point please sign up
and with that I would like to thank you
all for your time and your attention and
I'll give control over to Ross so that
he can push the poll question out and
then we'll take questions from you thank
you very much
Ross over to you all right thank you so
much akash for a great presentation as
we move into the Q&A portion of the
webinar we'll push out one final poll
question asking you what you got out of
this webinar and what your thoughts are
on a UC as a reminder you can submit
questions by clicking on the ask a
question box located on the far left of
your screen and with that we'll get
started with the first question
so Akash what is the process for data
collection and analysis all right Russ
thank you so the process for data
collection and analysis okay so this is
a two-part question let's break this up
the way the experiment is set up is from
your browser the actual AUC instrument
is controlled by an on-board computer
the way you communicate with that AUC
instrument is via your laptop using
Firefox or Safari or Chrome or whatever
browser you want to so you don't need to
install any specific or custom software
to control the instrument once the
experiment is completed then you can
download the data from the Optima you
see also directly from the browser onto
your laptop and once that data has been
downloaded in zip format then you can
unpack it and then you can use a number
of different software packages to
analyze the data the user community has
developed several sub software packages
- packages which are very commonly used
and are quite popular and set fit and
ultra scan and we will be giving you a
brief overview of these packages in
subsequent webinars
all right thanks Akash the next question
is if I have a sample to run how do I
choose to run parameters and where would
I go to find information to get started
okay excellent question so if you have a
sample to run depending on what kind of
sample it is there are several pre
experiment input parameters which you
will try to find some of these
parameters are fairly easy for example
if you are dealing with a protein sample
you know what the average density of
most proteins are like if you are
dealing with a nucleic acid sample again
you know what the average density of
most nucleic acid samples are like the
different user community based analysis
packages that I had mentioned ultra scan
and said fit they actually have very
useful simulation modules built into the
systems where you can plug in the
estimated parameters of your system of
interest such as estimated molecular
weight whether it associates
what is its density so on and so forth
and they can actually generate a
suggested rotation speed for the rotor
for you in fact they can they can
generate suggested experiment protocols
for you at this point
all right Thank You Akash the next
question we have is what is a UCS
throughput and how many samples might I
be able to run in a day
ok so let's work that through if you're
using an eight hole rotor then you have
to account for one of the fact one of
the holes is a counterbalance which has
to be here so you can do seven samples
at one go and if you are doing a
sedimentation velocity experiment you
can probably do an experiment in six
hours or there abouts so really you're
looking at perhaps 14 samples in a
workday
all right thank you next question is I
have a protium lab and what kind of
operating system do I need to run on the
new Optima UC and how does this differ
from my current setup okay
so again very good question
whatever operating system you like the
reason is that the control of the Optima
a UC is via browser the system has an
on-board computer which you don't need
to worry about because that is something
which is maintained via software
upgrades that we will provide in order
for setting up an experiment and
downloading the data you can use
whatever operating systems that you have
on your laptop and as long as you are
able to set it up on the same network
you just connect to the instrument via
browser and download data server via
browser it is basically platform
agnostic
all right great the next question is
asking what is the purpose of the air
gap in the sample sector
well you don't you want to have a small
amount of air gap because you don't want
and you will end up having a small
amount of air gap because you don't want
to load sample all the way because you
simply want to balance things properly
however you also want to keep the length
of the air gap as small as possible
because the quality of your data and the
resolution of your experiment will
depend to a certain extent upon the
length of the sample column so if your
air gap is huge and occupies half of the
length of the sample column then you're
basically throwing away data which you
should have alright thank you the next
question is what sort of information can
we see with nanoparticles what sort of
information can receive with
nanoparticles an experiment well
nanoparticles should typically give you
a distribution of a population
distribution of size and molecular
weight and if you are seeing aggregation
then AUC should also be able to quantify
that aggregation and if you're also
seeing the appearance of aggregates
which have some kind of unusual and
isotropic property then that that
anisotropy or that distortion of shape
is also something which you should be
able to obtain via NAAC experiment the
okay the next question is are there any
application areas for AC with vaccines
that's an excellent question
UC is basically something which can
determine whether a given prep of any
kind of biological system is homogeneous
or heterogeneous so therefore if you are
interested in quantifying or doing some
kind of QC work on any biological system
including for example deactivated
viruses and you just want a prep which
is as homogeneous as possible then yes a
UC can answer that question it can tell
you whether your prep is homogeneous or
whether you're dealing with a very
heterogeneous mix of things deactivated
viruses broken up viral capsids just
free protein fragments floating around
in your formulation buffer it can tell
you whether you have all of these things
or not okay great the next one is asking
if it is possible to use AC to get
analysis of plastic polymers yes it is
it's I have actually done some
experiments recently on plastic polymers
and depending on depending on these
let's say the oligomerization behavior
of these polymers your experiments can
give you very high resolution
information or they can give you a very
broad distribution of sedimentation
coefficients which again will tell you
that the polymer that you're looking at
is actually quite heterogeneous in terms
of its distribution of monomeric units
okay next up is a question about the
objects asking is 280 nano meter light
is available yes sir 280 nano meter UV
absorbance is the standard wavelength
which we look at for looking at proteins
because that is of course where the side
chains will absorb it's also possible to
look at
hundred thirty nanometers which is where
the peptide bond will absorb if you're
looking at smaller concentration protein
samples and it's possible to do that in
the same experiment because the Optima
you see as I've mentioned is an amazing
instrument which brings to you
multi-wavelength capabilities okay
excellent
the next question is asking what sort of
interferences might never be with lipids
in the separation that you're using for
AZ I'm sorry can you please repeat that
question please yeah of course it's
asking what sort of interferences do you
get with lipids in your separation okay
so that is um that's actually a fairly
complicated question so so let's let's
try to break this down is the lipid the
analyte that you're trying to look at or
is the lipid just something which exists
in the buffer but is not actually the
analyte these are two different things
obviously if you're looking at lip as
lipids as the analyte then yes you can
quantify what's going on and after all
the liposome is essentially nothing but
a construct which is made up of lipids
right so yes you can look at lipids in
an AUC experiment however if the lipid
is not the analyte but it is something
which is present in the formulation
buffer then that is something that
you'll have to account for
mathematically while doing the analysis
what it will end up doing is that it
will end up changing the effective
density of the buffer and that has to be
somehow mathematically accounted for but
it can be done
okay next question is why would I choose
certain centerpiece compositions over
the other so looking at epoxy aluminum
okay excellent question
so the epoxy or epon centerpieces are
related to go up to 45,000 rpm the
aluminium centerpieces are related to go
up to 60,000 rpm so if you're looking at
some kind of a system which is quite
small and therefore you have to run at a
much higher speed in order to see its
sediment properly then you would
probably want to use the aluminium
centerpiece simply because it goes up to
a higher speed of course you would want
to check the chemical compatibility of
your system with the aluminum
centerpiece before you proceed with such
an experiment
okay great given the amount of time I
think we have questioned for time for
one more question asking what volume in
tighter is required for doing ACC
analysis of a AVS okay so the volume of
an AUC X sample is going to be around
450 microliters give or take a little
bit and what is the tighter the best way
to answer that question is to take a
little bit of your sample and put it on
a nano drop or whatever level other UV
spec that you have and if you're looking
at 230 nanometers which is what we would
prefer to look at then you need to have
absorption values of between point 1 to
1 units on a 10 millimeter path length
that is the amount of sample that you
would like to have all right Thank You
Akash do you have any final comments for
our audience regarding AUC before we
close things up yeah sure so AUC is an
amazing technique it is really a Swiss
Army knife of biophysics and the
limitations of what you can do with a UC
are honestly only limited by your
imagination so reach out to us tell us
what kind of kind of sample systems you
would like us to talk about in
subsequent webinars and we'll get back
to you and we'll try to address those
systems thank you very much for your
time and your attention
and we hope to hear from you shortly
thank you all right Akash thank you
again for taking the time to discuss the
opportunities Auz I'd like to also thank
laborat and our sponsor Beckman Coulter
life sciences before we go I'd like to
finally thank the audience for joining
us today and participating for any
questions we didn't have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period well we will address those
by the speaker via contact information
provided when you registered when the
webinar recording is available for
replay you will receive an email from
laberd's and I encourage you to share
that recording with any colleagues who
may have missed today's live event I
hope to see you again at the next AC
webinar and until then good bye